good to see you good to see you too
you know it's oh thanks guys
nice and not nice
i live just down the street yeah
they're all going to follow you home
ladies please uh you know it's funny
because the last time i saw you i never
run
into celebrities anywhere i think
they're avoiding me
last christmas i'm hanging out at my
house and my you know with my brothers
and sisters and we're hanging out and
our parents are saying have more ribbon
candy
and after you know when it gets to be
like nine o'clock you're like we're
gonna just go out for just a little bit
mom and dad and so we all piled into a
station wagon and we went
to is it somerville i'm trying to think
about cambridge well it was actually in
cambridge
b-side lounge this bar and i get there
and it's just this bar that you don't
hear about that much but it's this great
place
so i went through with my brother and
sister the place is completely empty
and i'm sitting there i'm at the bar and
i'm having like some peanuts and a
girly pina colada or something and tap
tap tap matt damon is there and you and
i hung out in this bar for a while it
was really fun yeah which was really
we have this tradition we have a similar
tradition yeah with the in our family
where we kind of sneak out at around
nine o'clock or something
and uh and we get together with all like
our old high school friends and
everybody and i think the weird cause
that
never happens to me either i never bump
into celebrities and the weirdest part
about that night i think was the fact
that my friends didn't think it was that
weird that
we were hanging out together people just
think that like well we saw you on tv
interviewing matt so i'm sure you guys
later on
you know hook up at a bar right on
christmas night no and then
soon you know soon eric estrada comes in
hey fellas that's right
you know cheech marin and the place
filled up with
i i think i was more excited than any of
my friends i was like conan o'brien wow
he's in the bar and they were like yeah
yeah dude i mean of course
you're like you don't understand this
guy's a god
okay you didn't say that i lied no no i
said that
you did say that because i asked you to
say that it was really funny too because
you know
i think we just told our parents we're
just going to the mass we're going to go
to mass again
yeah right see how jesus is doing and
then you come back later on you're like
whoa man
yeah i think that was your opener don't
tell my mom we're not the man yeah
exactly
so uh this is an exciting thing uh
you're hosting starting out live
musical guest bruce springsteen yeah
this week yeah
uh and the e street band and this is the
day that they rehearse the music
yeah and so i got it early you came in
early i know i did
our studio here is just about two floors
away so we ran
up there and we all watched you just sit
there and you watch the rehearsal for
the music and it's
pretty cool it was unbelievable he's one
of the uh one of the
only people that i really get just geeky
around
you know so he's someone who makes he he
intimidates you because he's that yeah
i just really have been such a it's not
even a star it's the i've just
loved the guy i love his music i love
just i mean just he's an incredible guy
and i and i just
you know
and after a while like it's like all
right all right take it easy matt right
yeah yeah
he was he was he was pretty conspicuous
about how hard he was trying to avoid me
i think
now who is there anybody else uh who
sort of who you would say get stage
fright around or is there anyone of that
magnitude
actually the uh my probably one of my
more embarrassing moments maybe my most
embarrassing moment in my life
happened in front of president clinton
um
he was somebody who i got stage fright
around literally
uh we went to camp david the show good
will hunting and uh
we you know robin williams was there and
after the movie i had to go to the
to the bathroom and so i went into this
uh bathroom facility
and the president was the only other
person in there you know and i i was are
you sure you want to talk about this
all right come on i get paid to do that
but he you know the all day he i mean
he's you know
the president obviously very busy man
and he was and he
i thought did a great job and and was
working constantly and so he kind of had
this moment of
peace in the bathroom and i didn't want
to disturb him so he he was at the
at the bank of urinals and uh and so a
bank of urinals at camp david
well yeah like three three lined up next
to each other and they used to be a
greyhound bus station
they converted it right right so i went
i said well i'll go in the stall i won't
bother the president i'll
so i went into the stall and i really
had to go to the bathroom and uh
suddenly you know i i couldn't
you know i mean yeah i mean i mean stage
fright
right right right and i at first i went
you know
no no this this this isn't gonna happen
to me right and then
the second started turning into like
minutes and uh
and clinton wasn't leaving because it
was like his first
first kind of peaceful moment of the day
so he's washing his hands he's whistling
you know and this is going on and now
i'm getting you know
i'm getting really desperate right right
now come on
[Laughter]
and uh calm thoughts think conflicts
yeah and you know think about waterfalls
and stuff like that
and and now i and now i'm thinking i'm
getting really self-conscious i'm like
he's actually waiting to hear
if i if i if i'm gonna go
and uh matt you having a little trouble
in there yeah
you know i've been doing this a little
longer than you thought
i'll give you a couple tips yeah um
and uh and eventually uh he he
mercifully left after about three
minutes and then it was like the hoover
dam broke you know
i can't imagine that because you would
start to think oh my god he's noticing
now i've got to do something no that was
exactly where my head went immediately
and then and then talk about brain
freeze i mean it was total brain lock i
just you know
well you survived it and now let me ask
you about i i have a question for you
because
uh i referenced it but i think people
just thought i was putting down boston
i'm from the boston area as well
and i was curious when i did ceremony
live like a year and a half ago
they have a sketch where people talk in
boston accents right right and i thought
they're probably going to
want you to do that too all i know is
that i'm from there
but i had forgotten how to do a boston
accent because i've been gone
so long right and so they actually were
trying to teach it
to me they were going like no it's the
ad the ad i'm going the yard
no yet can you connect with it again
is it well i'm a professional actor
conan so
man i should have hit you when we were
in that bar
that was my chance we're not getting
together at christmas again this year
that's right right
man i'm going with estrada i'm leaving
you out
uh no but it's it's tough it's tough
tour if you're from there you get
self-conscious about at least i feel
well it's and it's also you know you go
through such an effort to lose it and i
mean i think
if you had listened closely that night
at the bar i mean i get a few in me and
it comes right back at i'm like conan
how you doing brother
so you know yeah so are you gonna do
that sketch or you don't know yet uh
well you know
you never know what's gonna make it to
air but that's one of the selects it
looks like and uh and then we there's
some other kind of funny stuff
i actually kind of like coming on the
show and not having anything to promote
like i don't have a movie coming out i
don't have you know
anything really to do i just couldn't
really get springsteen tickets
you're like all right this is the only
way to hang out with him before we go i
have to ask
i heard this and i don't know if it's
true but that people on the street
because you two
because you and ben affleck are so
closely associated with each other that
people on the street sometimes call you
ben all the time they call me ben or
what's worse is they say you know
matt and i go hey and they go where's
ben
where's he supposed to be he's doing a
movie right now i mean we don't hang out
together
all the time you know so people want to
see the two of you on a bicycle built
for two
yeah like yeah like
that's hilarious arm and arm like
skipping down skipping along the lane
come on just do that once and freak
people out
oh god that'd be the end of it anyway
though
or the beginning think of it that way uh
matt of course as we said hosting the
season premiere of sarnot live this week
with musical guest bruce springsteen in
the e street band that's going to be
an awesome show yeah and uh you know
what thrilled to have you here thanks
for being here
rita wilson